we were talking a moment ago about you
know leftist gun control and i wanted to
pull up this story
this is from fox news parkland activist
calls out media for not
aiding gun reform efforts under biden
after doing so under trump
suddenly you're just an angry leftist
who will never be happy with
anything that cameron caskey said i
don't think
cameron caskey is a leftist at all uh
leftist he's just a theater kid
he's a yeah he's theater kid but he's
more like an establishment democrat so i
i don't see him as like a socialist i
don't think he posts this stuff maybe he
does maybe i'm wrong
but there's a big difference between the
leftists like the antifa types
who are literally like wanting an
insurrection and buying a bunch of guns
and quoting marks all day when mark said
you know
under no pretext shall arms and
ammunition be surrendered the workers
must frustrate this
with force if necessary he is just an
establishment guy right so these are
like the elites these are
the the um the uh shocked
nobility of capital city going like egad
the people have gone
how could they he's surprised now that
the media has completely abandoned him
now that joe biden is president and they
don't need his vote anymore
it's funny how that happens isn't it he
said quote
right now this very moment is very
complicated it's a very
complicated time for gun violence
prevention activists
they're not but anyway because with
biden and white house the media does not
want to aid
us in demanding stronger gun reforms
because whatever joe biden does is
suddenly the right thing to do caskey
said
when donald trump was the president
calling for an assault weapons ban and
saying that the measures
that he was putting in place were not
nearly enough was a very popular opinion
now if you're calling for an assault
weapons ban certainly just an angry
leftist
who will never be happy with anything
that was always true
they were using you to try and get
donald trump out of office
the assault weapon ban would have never
done anything and that's why
your ideas don't make sense but it's no
surprise that the media is like
we're out yeah they didn't want to help
him in the first place well and now i
mean i tweeted this because
i think the washington post had an op-ed
about how uh biden's
uh white house is the most blue-collar
white house in history which is
like completely not true but i guess if
you have a job you're considered blue
collar
and i said you know clinton got fellatio
from one intern now the entire press
corps is doing it for biden left and
right
they love him or they love what he's
representing or allowing to happen yeah
biden is the greatest president of this
or any generation the greatest problem
enough times people start to believe it
did you could you imagine the people who
you know don't watch the news anymore
who actually believe that where you've
got a guy who goes on tv and he says
true in another shop at a pressure
and they think this guy is capable of
running a country and and the thing is
he's remarkably radical like i mean
biden is
far more radical than i even thought
that he would be he's very very far to
the left with things that he's doing
and people still consider him a moderate
and it's just bizarre to me and he's
like this fragile old guy that they're
like oh no he's finding somebody
no he's what the things that he's doing
he just got rid of that monument
like that monument ban who was sitting
there saying oh man
i was going to destroy a monument today
but trump did that executive order and
he was like no i'll be your advocate you
could destroy monuments again.
why like why like why was that the thing
that he was like i gotta do this
and maybe it's just been the face of
trump i don't know but it's it's bizarre
i do i do think you you're you're being
a little unfair to joe biden
all right yeah so i i wanna i wanna read
you uh i wanna read you a quote it's
very profound
and um inspirational something that joe
biden said that's gonna make you at
least you gotta give him some credit joe
biden said
the best way to get something done if
you
if you hold it near and dear to you that
you like to be able to anyway
is that a real quote yes when was that
recent i don't know
that's i think you can listen to him say
it i wonder if i can find the video
i hate it it's worse than the way i read
it i was
that was a commencement speech problem i
was trying to read that as if it were
all right let's let's see if this is it
can we play it
i'm a very very practical guy yeah
okay i can't make it any louder though
huh
i don't think can anybody hear this i
don't think they can hear it oh
because it's i can't make it any louder
than it is um that's a presentation
let me try and find a better video yeah
he uh
yeah his whole thing about any i i don't
know i think that biden
is bryden's has these grand like you
know proposals
that are large and trillions of dollars
and that's what you do after you're
lyndon johnson and win 46 states and
that's after
you when you're fdr and you win you know
i guess there was only 48 states at the
time 47 states at this time so 45
or or reagan after he won 49 or nixon
for 49.
this is what he did where he won by 45
000 votes in three states and
a 50 50 senate and law seats in the
house i think it's because he knows he's
not going to be there for very long and
do you remember when i think it was
somebody in the press who was talking
about how great it is that they can use
biden to make it look like what they're
doing is not
radical he's like everyone thinks he's
super nice but we're being able to get
all this stuff done but isn't it funny
how uh kamala has
far lower approval ratings than he does
i mean
it's not surprising at all she is the
hillary clinton factor where she's not a
likeable person
she's just got that natural that laugh
is rough
but she has that natural thing and yeah
maybe he's just likable and people
and people will sit there and excuse it
but it is really
horrendous and if you know if we go into
next year
i mean that i mean his approval ratings
i think are at 52 51 53
about and his disapprovals are in the
mid 40s which is very average for
you know 100 day 128th president
okay go ahead you play i got it
no i don't i don't think it's working i
don't think people want man but i can
hear it no no i don't i can hear it too
but yeah i don't think it's getting
picked up on the uh
live stream yeah on the live stream
whatever yeah oh well you can't hear it
but uh yeah so the best way to get
something done if you if you hold near
and dear to you
that you uh yum like to be able to
anyway and that's and that's not that's
not uh his like tick that he has where
he can't speak that's not stutter forgot
what he was saying
can i just
yeah it's actually it's actually here
transcribed oh my god
it's actually transcribed on
whitehouse.gov exactly
it is a a quote from joe biden yeah and
that will never be i mean that will
never be
looked at all of his you know biden isms
the way that trump used to say like
everything was the greatest the most
wonderful the best
that was i mean mocked ridiculously
biden's
falling apart the issue with biden is
that
every journalist does this including
conservative journalists
joe biden will say something like we we
gotta
uh you know uh gotta lumber prices are
too high we
we gotta get lumber prices you know uh
down
and then the conservatives will write
joe biden said quote we got to get
lumber prices down
yes no he didn't he said um
the pressure yeah everything speaks like
foghorn
from like the looney tunes yeah yeah i
mean
and and everyone says they're insane no
that's absolutely true uh
and you know my grandfather died of
parkinson's and my grandmother's
dementia i'm very used to
and when he had park parkinson's he got
louis dementia i
know dementia i'm not like a doctor
whatever and i don't think that he has
any advanced stages of of
it but even if he's the perfectly most
healthy person in the world he is a man
of a particular age
and you know yeah there are a handful of
men who go into their 80s
you know the clint eastwoods of their of
the world they can still sit there and
work and operate
but joe biden is not that he's 87 right
88 no no he's
79 79 79 80. he's either nine or eight
eight seven eight well i mean he's ages
decrepit
he's definitely not uh he's definitely
spry i don't say decrepit about many
lives
november but that's but he is but he's
only five years older than trump
and look at like that even in the last
two years his exhaustion level is just
over two well he stops working in a lot
or he like
he has he can't be around the press
after like a certain hours a day doesn't
answer questions
you guys need to look look this up on
your phones real quick i'm going to show
everyone who's watching
there's an article from the onion stress
presidency
already ages biden 10 years yes and he
looks like
a mummy he looks desiccated
yeah it's just like a rotten corpse just
like
10 years that's
kind of that's what it feels like the
last two years has just
it's just aged him his voice is so much
more tired
what you need to understand my friend is
that as you're older and older it's an
exponential decline
yeah you know i guess the older you get
the faster your decline is
you know you look at their theirs i'm
not going to name anybody but there are
some people that i used to you know look
up to who are old and passed on and it's
like you could really see that decline
happen man faster and faster yeah yeah
yeah their opponent is not one of those
people
in your 60s to your 70s people in
general
most people i've witnessed go to the age
range don't decline very much
70s to 80s is a big slowdown and 80s to
90s now is where he's approaching i mean
very few people are betty white
it's like movement or william or william
shatner
i think he's actually like data from
yeah yeah
or like dick van dyke there are a
handful of cloris leech men well there's
a handful
of uh people mel brooks who like in
their 90s
stellar better than i am my 30s um he is
not
the president united states currently
and also it's weird when you look at
foreign countries
like the president of austria is my age
yes and you're like or like the like
the chancellor no no austria oh yeah
yeah
but macron is young too he's in the 30s
the guy in italy is like
31 like there are people like the rest
of the world
has like people uh like it
it's like if you see star wars phantom
menace and like the princess princess
is like 13 14 and she's like the dem
that's what like the rest of the world
looks like compared to our leaders
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you